Hey youtubers it's Charlie and
Ryan Reynolds just started blowing up the
internet with Deadpool talk so I'm going to
do an update on where the movie is at in terms
of development.
Also Krysten Ritter was just cast as Jessica
Jones in the Marvel Netflix Series.
So I'll explain that after Deadpool Chimichangas.
Important stuff first, Ryan Reynolds is ending
the financial arm wrestling with Fox over
his contract.
He'll star in it of course but he'll also
be a producer.
Sometimes on actor driven movies like this
they'll give actors producer credits to sweeten
the deal and give them some creative control
over the output.
That can be anything from script approval
to control in the editing bay.
Hugh Jackman has this kind of deal on all
his Wolverine movies.
Actually that's not true, he has way more
control over those movies.
The more successful franchises are and the
bigger the actors are, the more control they
get.
Par for the course in Hollywood.
Even though this is technically a Fox movie,
Marvel is getting involved.
Kevin Feige is getting a full producer credit
on the film.
He's still the president of Marvel Studios.
So yeah, it could mean a lot of things.
I think it's mostly to boost the potential
earnings.
Feige is the creative engine behind all the
things Marvel has done with it's films.
I mean he has Joss Whedon and James Gunn on
staff.
And an army of really awesome writers.
But all the big moves come from his brain.
So I think Fox was a lot quicker to greenlight
the film with a bigger budget after Fiege
agreed to collaborate with the writers and
director on Deadpool.
They're calling it a Fox slash Marvel film.
But I don't think Marvel
is co-financing.
I think they're involvement is purely on the
creative level.
There is an old script by Rhett Reese and
Paul Wernick.
That's from way back when they first started
working on the film.
That version of the movie was more of a self-contained
Deadpool story.
Now Fox has officially said it's going to
be an X-Men Spinoff.
So they'll be able to reference Days of Future
Past, X-Men Apocalypse, etc.
You get the idea.
Don't expect Michael Fassbender or Jennifer
Lawrence to cameo, but depending on the story
they go with, it's a lot easier for them to
include X-Men characters.
Even though it is a collaboration with Marvel,
I wouldn't expect to see any Marvel Movie
characters.
Punisher would be a lot of fun.
Marvel owns the rights to that character again
and he's not getting his own film any time
soon.
But just in general, only expect to see cameos
from characters that Fox owns.
Which is X-Men and Fantastic Four.
And right now Fantastic Four is way off in
it's own universe of development purgatory.
I think Fox is kind of afraid of what's going
to happen with that film just because they've
made huge changes to the continuity.
That's something for a whole other video.
Here's a few things we do know about the movie.
It has a release date, February 2016.
That's a soft date.
So expect it to change a little depending
on how quickly they can start actually shooting
footage.
The original director Tim Miller is still
attached.
And the original writers are still attached.
Ryan Reynolds has been loosely associated
with the project since they first talked about
it way back in 2008, then in 2011 when they
shot the test footage that everyone saw at
comic con.
The only reason people are talking about him
now is because his original contract lapsed
because of all the time that passed.
So officialy up to this point, Fox didn't
own his soul.
That's the easiest way to kill a movie, when
an actor won't sign a new contract.
The same thing will happen eventually with
Hugh Jackman and Wolverine.
But he, along wit Robert Downey Jr, seem content
to ride their characters into old age.
In terms of the stories I think they should
do I did a TOP 5 video a little while ago
so I'll add a link in the description if you
want to learn more about that.
Because of Fiege and Marvel's involvement
I do think they'll pick one of the more notable
comic book stories and just adapt it.
Marvel changes little things about the movies
based on rights issues.
Sometimes they have to swap characters and
change origin stories.
Like Ultron and Vision's story in Avengers
2.
Jessica Jones: